- [Narrator] Once upon a
time, there was a mighty king.
It was said he ruled over a small island
off the coast of Sardinia.
Many had searched far and
wide for the lost king,
but still no one had found--
(tape screeching)
Wait a minute, that's him.
That's the king.
(trumpet music)
(speaks in foreign language)
(lively instrumental music)
- [Narrator] His family
has lived on the island
for over 200 years.
His great-great-grandfather,
Giuseppe Bertoleoni,
arrived on the uninhabited island in 1807.
The king of Sardinia, Carlo Alberto,
was, well, intrigued, so ...
- [Narrator] Goats with gold teeth?
- [Narrator] A Bertoleoni
coat of arms were painted,
flags were made, and a
royal family tree was drawn.
News had even reached Queen Victoria
who sent a photographer to
photograph the new royal family.
- [Narrator] So what is
a typical day in the life
of his lordship?
- [Narrator] Wait, a
ruler with a restaurant?
Are you really a king?
- [Narrator] Your
Majesty, I totally agree.
(gentle instrumental music)